what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel today i am going
to be reacting to
um a kevin samuels video sassy bus
driver doesn't want to settle
love girls on the kevin samuels show
that won't don't want to settle before i
start don't forget to subscribe to the
channel bring that notification bell
that way you're going to be notified of
my daily videos
um while you're at it
feel free
to leave a like
and a comment let me know what you think
you know help a girl out
all right all right
you got to go to the bathroom well i was
looking for some light
okay go ahead
i got my bathing suit on
um
hello
hi how are you
i'm will how old are you i'm 32.
all right any single or married
i'm single
any kids no
what you got
um i don't want to be nobody's side
chick because i want to be married um
you know i'm out on my own i've been
holding it down for my on my own
but it's kind of hard kevin because
like really when women say they want to
look for the right person
they got their own definition about that
but
it's hard it's hard because man it's
hard i tried and tried i'm 32 with no
kids i live on my i live on my own it's
nice
what's what's hard about it
it's just like
i need you to stay still you can't be
moving around like that the actions like
you know
no i don't no i don't
they act like they don't want to like
okay i need you okay hold up i need you
to stay still
and keep the camera steady so cause it's
making a bad
show for everybody else
okay
without you
uh i really don't understand what you're
talking about because what's the only
time
what's the
what's the only
go ahead
what's the only common denominator in
all of our relationships
i don't know
well i don't how do you not know i don't
know it's the patience
do you know what a common denominator is
yeah it's the bottom line yes i know no
that's not where the common denominator
is the same thing
what is it
the only common denominator in all of
our relationships is us
correct
but
man these days they is it's difficult
because they want they cake and eat it
too
it's always the man
it could be a woman too but okay
unpopular opinion your opinion on men is
more reflective on you than it is on men
and i say the same thing about women
your opinion on women is reflective
on the women you choose and your picking
ability rather than women
and we're talking about you so if i talk
to all your exes and ask them how do
they experience you what do you think
they'd say
they're gonna give good stuff out
they're gonna say i have a little
attitude and my mouth is slick but
that's about it
what do you mean that's it
that's about it that's what i was
thinking too
good i mean as far as the bad stuff but
you know they don't say i'm independent
you know i know this [ __ ] about you i
know if no disrespect man who gives a
[ __ ] that you're a functioning adult
okay
you're a functioning adult
i love him nobody cares about nobody
cares that you've been holding it down
that means you're taking care of
yourself
but you say they're gonna say
you got an attitude and a slick mouth
and that's it
so much so that you got an attitude and
a slick mouth
why do you think why do you what makes
women like you think that that's
acceptable
i speak my mind if i if nothing don't
feel right then
that's why you're alone that's why
you're alone
[Music]
brutal
why while you're alone
it's hard i don't want to be no no no no
it's not hard it's not hard acting right
shouldn't be this hard
[Music]
i'm a bus operator i work for the city
drive buses uh-huh so
you just do what the [ __ ] you want to in
the bus you just speed
you do whatever you want to do don't
obey the traffic laws i do okay so you
can act like right when the white man's
money's on the line
unfortunately
see how that works gentlemen see how
that work when when her holding it down
is jeopardized that white paycheck is on
the line then all of a sudden these
sassy slick mouth women think a show act
right well and that's why
i'm not believing the guy at all in this
situation but
as men you really should never be afraid
to walk away from a female like if you
don't feel like a female is respecting
you if you don't feel like a girl is
treating you the way you should be
treated
you should have no problem walking away
because otherwise people take advantage
and you don't want to give your partner
the opportunity to take advantage of you
it's not easy i live in la and it's it's
not listen to all these excuses listen
to all these excuses i don't have no
kids so
you don't have any kids do respect man
we don't have any kids what do you mean
settle you're a bus driver
you
i just want you guys to think for a
second that the world we live in towards
sassy
a attitude sassy mouth bus driver thinks
she's settling for somebody
that's how far that y'all don't
understand how bad you guys have got
because you're on here talking about how
hard it is you exactly where you you
sound like you need to be by yourself
on some occasions yeah i do
well you like dogs or cats
really
what you mean by that
i like
between dog or cat what would you pick
it'll definitely be a cat
okay we're good with that because see a
cat don't care about what comes out of
your mouth because they don't speak
human but it's not that's not what it's
going to be though one day you know
all right one day because right because
you know
human beings as they get older
only become
less like they are or more like they are
i tried to follow your
you know your advice but
i have i watch you all the time but i'm
telling it's i don't know why is it so
hard for you to behave
because i'm going to express myself like
if i feel like somebody trying to take
control of not even that's why i watch
these videos sometimes and i think she
actually has been pretty respectful
towards kevin but i will literally think
did you guys not have parents that
yelled at you
oh my gosh my mom would yell at me if i
used the wrong tone
like
oh my gosh in control like take
advantage of me i'm a capricorn so i'm
big hearty oh my gosh
is it bad that whenever i hear zodiac
signs i always assume the girl's a
little crazy
a little bit you cannot be that into
zodiac signs i'm so sick of black people
with this zodiac [ __ ]
i'm a capricorn it's hard all right so
what capricorn it's hard
well then what are your alternatives buy
a dog or cat and die alone
i mean it's hard right so hey you're in
l.a
you and the cat can eat the same food
we're talking about just simple common
decency and respect and i said how would
your exes tell me they experienced you
and you said it they would probably tell
you i have a bit of an attitude which is
a whole lot and a slick mouth well see
that's the problem you ladies are able
to talk crazy to men with no
consequences
so now what men are doing is just
avoiding you
you can't even give it away
and no one can no one men don't want to
tolerate this
we haven't even got to the important
stuff because you're just out of control
that's fine
you think that gets better with age
no i only get older
so since you seem to know those couple
of issues what are you doing about them
um i'm
nothing i'm working on it i'm gonna work
with who with who with who
nobody i don't i'm so in other words so
in other words she's not doing anything
not doing anything she knows her issues
and is doing absolutely nothing
so that's a formula for what kind of
outcome
do you think the marriages back in the
day is different no no no no no no no no
you got to answer my question before i
answer yours okay
that's a formula for what kind of
outcome
nothing
so what's your question
do you think the marriages is different
from like back in
yes
generation because
don't laugh stop stop stop stop you got
to stop and stop you you got to stop
when you touch your phone it cut off do
i think marriages back in the day are
different from today i said yes and you
said what
marriage don't last
no
no
you ladies don't last
you're lower quality than your
grandmother's
okay
your grandmothers were better women
they was raised different
they were better
i don't know i think my grandma parties
more than i do
i'm like dead serious at one time i took
care of my grandma after surgery okay
i'm like she had this
surgery i forgot what she had surgery on
but i was with her for like two weeks
this woman like a week after surgery was
having me drive her to the bar
weird time in my life
they understood the value of family they
believed in god
i believe that
she does believe in god
german catholic just means we drink
after church you know what i mean he's
doing what you need really
do the good through the bad
my best at my worst really
really
you're a christian
i'm not a christian
and what god are you talking about it's
only one god
which is who
but what i'm saying is no no no no no no
no no no no
i'm not a christian though he said you
believe in god i believe in jesus christ
yeah
the holy spirit yeah
but you're not a christian
why
because i'm not living every day as i'm
not doing it i'm not living every day
i'm not so again this is see this is why
i challenge women they talk about god
jesus is like cosmic santa claus to
barely give them what they want when
they want to
you're you're undisciplined man there's
no discipline you're under
no religious discipline this is why
y'all are less quality women than your
grandmothers your grandmother's uh
submitted themselves to something
greater y'all submit yourselves to your
bag
bus driver how are you submitting
yourself to a bag if you're a bus driver
like what next
that's how low the standard is i mean i
mean bus driving whatever job i mean
whatever job yeah the average black one
makes 20 the average black women in this
country make 28 000 a year but they'd
rather have 28 000
and no and no husband that's a bag
damn 28 000 a year that's like nothing
you can't get along with a man
that's the problem
yeah
so
if you're not going to do anything to
fix it that means you're going to live
your life by yourself
unless you see a different outcome
do you
no like you said have you changed you
know working okay so let's go let's
let's let's fast forward 30 years
how long have you been working how long
have you been working for the city well
i mean i don't think my job got nothing
to do with
you know how long you been working
how long have you working for the city
seven years
you plan on retiring with this job
no
okay
uh what what job do you plan on what do
you plan on doing until 65.
i want to open up a business
doing what
i want to do an animal spa business i
like animals so
that was
did you go to college
no some college i didn't finish so where
do you plan on getting the money to
start this business
good question
so in other words you're just talking
so in other words you're just talking
and drinking kevin is so good at like
pulling away the layers of bs that women
tell brainstorming yeah you know talking
and dreaming see i like [ __ ] what
i hate the word manifesting i hate it
my boyfriend believes in that and like
loves that word or whatever but i just
no i don't know it just sounds like
nonsense to me talking and dreaming
manifesting that's correct honking and
dreaming
you have no money to start a business
and being an animal spa
is going to give you 2.7 million dollars
to retire
what do i have to do with a man
she don't even get it
i get it
you ain't gonna hit a man because your
attitude's too bad so if you can't if
you can't behave and act right i don't
know i'm going to deal with this so
you're going to take care of yourself
till you die
that's what it that's what it got to do
with it
because you got a slick mouth and you
kind of got an attitude that means that
nobody gonna couple with you that means
you got to take care of you until you
die
and the job you're working right now is
a job it ain't nothing to retire on
no children no husband means what
happens when you can't work or you get
sick
you gonna be on the street
i absolutely i understand trust i fail
you on that so all this i'm so that's
why i said
i'm i'm talking i'm manifesting that
means the jesus i don't the god i do not
follow and the life i don't live he's
supposed to manifest and give me stuff
[Music]
okay i'm gonna just say this man far too
many of our women okay um
sorry
when um
i switched to the main scene
kevin samuels hit the nail on the head
again
but it's almost like too easy for his
show
like
the girls that call in
always seem like a little off
but let me know in the comments what you
guys think don't forget to subscribe to
the channel ring the notification bell
i'll talk to you guys next time